one of the odder features of self-hatred
is that the affliction may escape our
notice for the greater part of our lives
we may simply not be aware that we don't
like ourselves very much even as the
sickness of self-hatred wrecks its havoc
across a range of psychological
situations and opportunities
though we are relentless scrutinizers of
others we seldom pause to give a unitary
verdict on what we make of our own
characters
we may recognize our approval or
distaste of ourselves in relation to
specific actions
we will know when we are for example
cross about being slow to complete a
task
or when we are pleased to have won a
colleague's approval but we are on the
whole uninclined to step far back and
consider ourselves in totality as we
might a stranger
we are too involved with ourselves on an
ongoing basis to assess the sharper
outlines of our own characters
there are few occasions when we are
summoned to ask whether we essentially
like the person we are
as a result our self-suspicion tends to
linger in undiagnosed forms
we miss the extent to which we can
suffer from endemic self-loathing and
how a once acceptable and perhaps
invigorating form of self-questioning
has turned into a lacerating sequence of
attacks on everything we are and do
we may paradoxically be at once highly
depressed about ourselves and oblivious
that we are so
in order to know what we are up against
we should take a measure of our sense of
self
for this there may be no better move
than to resort to that clumsiest but
simple and most helpful of psychological
tools the questionnaire
we can ask to what extent we might agree
with the following sentences on a scale
of one to ten
ten meaning very much
zero indicating not at all
if people knew who i really was they
would be horrified
the inside of me is appalling
often i can't bear who i am
i'm disgusting
i'm shameful
i'm weak
others have a good cause to hate and
harm me it's only a matter of time
before terrible things happen to me
given who i am
i'm sexually revolting
i am physically repulsive
i am unworthy of being forgiven
i am a fitting target for ridicule
i am bound to fail
i don't deserve much sympathy
people often see me in the street and
feel contempt
i have acted badly across my whole life
there is something fundamentally wrong
with me
we don't need to do careful sums to
arrive at an indicative picture at speed
some of us will be reaching for tens on
pretty much every occasion
others blessedly will be puzzled by the
whole exercise
this book is not for them
if we find ourselves reaching for high
numbers we may be tempted to come to a
powerful yet entirely mistaken
conclusion
that we are terrible people
the reality is at once less personally
damning and far more redemptive
we aren't so terrible at all we are just
very ill
the questionnaire is telling us about an
affliction not about our past or what we
deserve or who we really are
the very extremity of our answers should
signal that something is afoot that far
exceeds what any human is ever owed
we aren't intolerably wicked we are in
the grip of a cruel sickness which
systematically destroys any confidence
or generosity we might feel towards
ourselves
we are treating ourselves with a
violence and pitilessness we wouldn't
think of bestowing upon our worst
enemies
we have somehow unbeknownst to us ended
up considering the person we have to
accompany through life with an
unparalleled degree of coldness and
disdain
it is time to come to terms with our
suffering and to refuse the delusion and
meanness of self-hatred
our emotional first aid kit provides a
set of useful sounds to some of life's
most challenging psychological
situations
including friendship love sex work and
self
click the link on screen now to find out
more